les bars et restaurants sont donc
condamnés à rester fermés au moins
jusqu'à la mi février une situation qui
pénalise aussi toute une filière en
amont c'est le cas de sean distribution
l'un des principaux fournisseurs de
boissons en france l'entreprise
familiale basée à châteauroux livre
d'ordinaire 400 clients en indre et
loire
grâce à son site de joué-les-tours site
aujourd'hui totalement à l'arrêt hélène
chapelet
ce chargement de quelques palettes de
boissons sera le seul de la semaine à
sortir des entrepôts jocondien de shon
distribution en temps normal sept à dix
tournées sont organisées chaque jour
pour réapprovisionner les bars et
restaurants du département en bois sont
diverses mais depuis la fermeture de ces
établissements le 29 octobre dernier
l'activité de ce grossiste est quasiment
à l'arrêt il ne livre plus que les ehpad
et quelques boulangeries
pas de quoi vider les stocks là vous
vous trouvez en fait dans un espace qui
est qui ne bouge plus depuis plus de
deux mois c'est à dire depuis la
fermeture des bars et où le stock en
fait est figé l'enfant dès 2500 2800 fut
en fait que vous avez autour de vous
doit être vendu logiquement sur un mois
et aurait déjà dû être vendus depuis la
fin du mois de novembre alors qu'il est
toujours là en stock et
et et qu'on n'attend qu'une seule chose
nous c'est que nos clients puissent
rouvrir dans les allées de cet entrepôt
de 3600 mètres carrés aucun bruit
il faut dire que les 35 salariés sont
tous au chômage partiel en 2020 une
entreprise a connu cinq mois d'activité
perturbé et n'a réalisé que 50% de son
chiffre d'affaires habituel
aujourd'hui son dirigeant tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
ils ne bénéficient pas des mêmes aides
que les bars et restaurants n'a
quasiment plus de revenus et continue à
payer des frais fixes très élevés sur le
site de joué-les-tours
si vous voulez un montant on est autour
de 120 mille euros par mois donc c'est
une somme qui il faut décaisser tous les
mois en attendant une réouverture et qui
nous pénalise et qui nous pénalisera
certainement dans les mois et les années
à venir si on n'a pas de perspective
d'accompagnement on se sent méprisée
oublier sacrifiés peut-être parce qu'on
n'est pas connue en fait aujourd'hui
mais on est un maillon essentiel en fait
de la chaîne 2 de fonctionnement de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration pour
alerter le gouvernement sur leur
situation les distributeurs et
grossistes en boisson manifesteront le
19 janvier partout en france
xavier lui se rendra à orléans pour se
faire entendre